I think there's a lot of humor
in this show.
Yeah. I'm funny.
You're very funny.
You're without filter,
which causes my character
a lot of problems.
(LAUGHTER)
♪ (LIVELY MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
So, episode three starts
when I'm letting Lucia and Mia
out of my room,
and you see that.
Good morning!
Morning.
And I ask you...
Please don't say anything
about any of this to Albie,
okay, Dad, please?
Look at those cannolis.
MICHAEL IMPERIOLI: You have
a bit of a loose tongue,
and I don't know if that's
deliberate or just accidental.
Honest. I don't speak
with forked tongue.
I guess so.
I made a plan for us today.
You should come.
-That's okay.
-She's coming.
I think Dominic's fine
with Portia coming along.
He's happy to see his son
make a connection with someone,
especially a smart,
nice, young woman.
I think that
my character's delighted
to have a young,
attractive woman around.
He's very concerned about
still being attractive to women
who are one third his age.
(LAUGHS) He's a little bit
unrealistic.
In other words, he's just
this common 82-year-old guy.
He's not gonna go gentle
into that good night, not Bert.
And I love him for that.
Do we embarrass you, Albie?
No, it's just,
I don't think you realize
how you sound sometimes.
What Albie brings is a balance
to our point of view,
and a perspective
that otherwise wouldn't exist,
not in our world.
He's helping Bert
to look at himself,
and he certainly is
helping your character.
My character's learning
from both you and him.
In some ways, he feels closer
to some of the ways you grew up,
and in some ways,
he feels closer to Albie.
And he doesn't want
to make the same mistakes.
He has made a lot of
the same mistakes you did,
but he wants to be able
to transcend them.
And he's looking towards Albie
to help him, in a way.
And he's kind of caught
between both of those places.
I need to change.
And so, I don't think
I'm gonna be able to meet up
at all this week.
This is for the ladies.
Jennifer's character
just tickles me to death.
Yeah, I was gonna say
the same thing.
-She's funny and-- yeah.
-F. MURRAY ABRAHAM:
She's a real hoot.
That's a good way to put it.
She'd be the most fun, probably.
I personally like
to go with the flow.
I might have a couple things,
like I wanna do this,
I wanna see that.
I don't like going
on tours very much
or being with other people
that I don't know,
like on some kind of tour.
I find that kind of confining.
But, you know, I always
do a little bit of research,
and make a point
of going to see some things
that are interesting.
Boy, considering how many
clothes this guy is wearing,
I'm not gonna carry that stuff.
I don't mind checking luggage.
Check it, baby.
I travel a lot,
just like you do,
and after a long trip,
you get up 5:00 in the morning.
And that's a great time
to go out and see a city.
-Yeah.
-ABRAHAM: You own the place.
You walk around
and you get a pretty good idea
of your bearings.
That's the way I like to travel.
Yeah.
And then, you know,
in the afternoon, you collapse.
Yeah, me too.
I'm an early riser.